[Musique]
ils étaient plus de 800 jeunes
réunionnais a participé à cette matinée
de rencontres sur la mobilité organisée
par le département
cette matinée d'échangés d'informations
permettait aux étudiants de trouver sur
un seul site tous les accompagnants
institutionnelle à la mobilité tout
trouvé pour pouvoir être des plus
possible encore wave ou l'intéressé oui
tous rassemblés rencontrer le cadre est
super donc du coup ça a l'air un peu de
pression mais c'est très intéressant
parce que c'est vrai que pour les
parents qui n'ont pas internet ou qui ne
savent pas comment faire il faut besoin
d'avoir une personne qu'on fasse plus
facile avec son dispositif ne bourse
chaque année la collectivité investit
près de 18 millions d'euros pour
favoriser la mobilité des étudiants
réunionnais le département accompagne
les jeunes par rapport à trois
dispositifs donc la bourse
départementale qui est le dispositif
phare du département
l'allocation de scolarité pour les
étudiants qui vont dans les filières
d'excellence dits d'excellence et écoles
d'ingénieurs les écoles de commerce et
on a un troisième dispositif qui
consiste à accueillir des étudiants
notamment sur paris on dispose d'un
droit de réservation pour 85 chambres à
la cité internationale universitaire de
paris et donc les étudiants peuvent
également bénéficier de ce dispositif
par rapport à la volonté du département
d'accompagner les étudiants au sein de
cet espace les étudiants finalisent
leurs projets de mobilité avec à leurs
côtés le département qui accompagne les
étudiants boursiers et qui favorise les
parcours d'excellence
[Musique]